using your laptop in public can be fun
but it can also be tricky
Gabby discreetly and quietly enjoys her
favorite shows and movies wearing
headphones and making sure the screen is
turned away from everyone else and when
she passes by someone else's screen she
minds her own business gabby is so
perfect and everyone loves her so much
they decide to put her face on a postage
stamp unlike Gabby whenever a Gertrude
watches something she turns the volume
up as loud as possible and makes sure
everyone knows she's enjoying it and
Gertrude isn't afraid to look over
someone else's shoulder invading their
personal space and making them feel
uncomfortable Gertrude is so terrible
and everyone hates her so much she can't
walk down the street without people
throwing rotten fruit at her via Gabby
not a Gertrude this message brought to
you by Intel who encourages you to mind
your mobile manners and tech responsibly